>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
ALL RIGHT, TAKE A SEAT, POUR A
COCKTAIL.
WE ARE ABOUT TO BLOW YOUR MIND.
FOR MORE THAN 30 YEARS,
NANCY PELOSI AS YOU WELL KNOW
HAS REPRESENTED THE SINGLE MOST
LIBERAL CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT
IN AMERICA.
SHE HAS ALWAYS BEEN PERFECTLY
SUITED FOR THE DROP YOUR NAME
THE ISSUE NO MATTER WHAT IT IS,
ABORTION, CLIMATE CHANGE,
PERMANENT ACTION, CLIMATE
CHANGE, NANCY PELOSI HAS THE PAR
CHANGE, NANCY PELOSI HAS THE PAY
CHANGE, NANCY PELOSI HAS THE PAA
CHANGE, NANCY PELOSI HAS THE PAP
CHANGE, NANCY PELOSI HAS THE PAO
CHANGE, NANCY PELOSI HAS THE PAE
CHANGE, NANCY PELOSI HAS THE PAD
POSITION ON THAT ISSUE.
SHE IS A WALKING LIBERAL
STEREOTYPE.
OR SO WE THOUGHT.
IN FACT, IT WAS ALL A SHAM
IDENTITY DESIGNED TO CLOAK A
DARKER BLUE      REALITY BENEATH
DARKER BLUE      REALITY BENEAT.
HE THOUGHT SHE WAS A LIBERAL WHO
ANNUALLY SENDS MONEY TO THE MBR
PLEDGE DRIVE, DIDN'T YOU?
NO.
IN FACT, PELOSI IS A COMMITTED
RACIST.
A HARDENED BIGOT.
SHE WOULD BE RUNNING THE LADIES
CLAN IF THEY HAD ONE IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
HOW DO WE KNOW THIS?
SIMPLE.
WATCH THE WAY NANCY PELOSI
DISMISSES FELLOW CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDER ACADIA CORTEZ.
IT'S BECAUSE SHE LIKES TO
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HER
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HEC
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HEU
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HES
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HEB
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HET
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HEE
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HEN
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HET
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HEE
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HEM
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HED
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HER
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HET
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HES
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HEA
MINIMIZE THE CONFLICT WITHIN HED
THE PROGRESSIVES.
>> YOU HAVE THESE WINGS, AOC AND
HER GROUP ON ONE SIDE.
>> IT'S LIKE FIVE PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: ACTUALLY, IT'S FOUR
PEOPLE.
BUT OF COURSE ARE RACIST WILL
GET THE NUMBER WRONG.
SHE WAS REFERRING TO ALEXANDER
ACADIA KERR TO HIS, ILHAN OMAR,
OR AS PELOSI DOUBTLESSLY THINKS
OF THEM, THE FOUR MORONS OF THE
APOCALYPSE.
PELOSI DOES NOT LIKE THEM, SHE
HAS MADE IT CLEAR.
AND OCASIO-CORTEZ THINKS SHE
KNOWS WHY.
IN A RECENT INTERVIEW WITH
"THE WASHINGTON POST,"
OCASIO-CORTEZ ACCUSED PELOSI OF
"SINGLING OUT A NEWLY ELECTED
WOMEN OF COLOR."
GET IT QWEST MARKET YAP.
PRESSED TO EXPLAIN HERSELF
LATER, OCASIO-CORTEZ NOTED THAT
PELOSI
HAS ATTACKED THESE WOMEN OF
COLOR DESPITE "KNOWING THE
AMOUNT OF DEATH THREATS THAT WE
GET.
I THINK IT IS JUST WORTH ASKING
WHY.
THAT IS A RHETORICAL QUESTION
OBVIOUSLY.
SHE KNOWS WHY.
WILES WOULD YOU IMPERIL
SOMEONE'S SAFETY?
BECAUSE YOU WISH THEM HARM.
BECAUSE YOU ARE A CRAZED BIGOT!
ACCORDING TO ALEXANDER ACADIA
CORTEZ, THAT IS WHO IS RUNNING
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY RIGHT NOW.
QUICK, WE'VE GOT A RACIST THIRD
IN LINE FOR THE PRESIDENCY.
I THINK WE ARE BEING TOO LITERAL
ABOUT THIS.
WHAT ARE THE ODDS IN REAL LIFE
THAT OCASIO-CORTEZ ACTUALLY
BELIEVES THAT NANCY PELOSI IS A
RACIST?
OR THAT JOE BIDEN IS A RACIST?
OR FOR THAT MATTER, DONALD TRUMP
IS A RACIST?
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES SHE REALLY
THINKS THAT?
PROBABLY ABOUT ZERO.
THE FIRST THING TO KNOW ABOUT
THE CRIES OF RACISM YOU HEAR
INCESSANTLY FROM THE LEFT, THEY
ARE TOTALLY INSINCERE.
NO ONE SAYING THAT ACTUALLY
BELIEVES IT.
THE POINT ISN'T TO GET RID OF
RACISM, THE POINT IS TO SEIZE
POWER AND IT WORKS.
DENOUNCING SOMEONE AS RACIST IS
THE KIND OF RHETORICAL STONE
GRENADE.
FOR THE MOMENT, THE ACCUSED JUST
STANDS THERE LOOKING BEWILDERED.
THAT IS WHEN YOU SCOOP UP THE
LOOT AND RUN.
IT IS A SMASH AND GRAB OPERATION
AND IT IS HIGHLY EFFECTIVE.
IT IS HOW THE LEFT HAS JUSTIFIED
ITS ENTIRE CLINICAL PROGRAM, AND
THE NAME OF FIGHTING BIGOTRY.
AMERICA HAS BEEN ACCUSED OF
RACISM THERE FOR WE MUST PICK
IT, LEGALIZE, GIVE UP THE FIRST
MOMENT, PAY FOR SOMEONE ELSE'S
ABORTION, TEAR DOWN OUR BORDERS
AND WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
ASK ABOUT CITIZENSHIP ON OUR
SENSES BOARD BECAUSE RACISM HERE
TO SEE HOW IT WORKS?
YEAH.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DID
NANCY PELOSI FALL FOR THIS?
SHE'S BEEN WORKING THE SCAMS
ALONG HERSELF YOU THINK SHE
WOULD SEE IT COMING BUT
APPARENTLY SHE DIDN'T.
McDONALD IS THE AUTHOR OF "THE
DIVERSITY DELUSION."
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
ARE YOU SURPRISED HAVING
FOLLOWED THIS ARGUMENT FOR SO
MANY YEARS SO CLOSELY, ARE YOU
SURPRISED THAT PELOSI AND BIDEN
ARE BEING DENOUNCED AS RACIST
RIGHT NOW?
>> COME IT IS HILARIOUS.
LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO SAVOR
THIS MOMENT.
THE LEFT TURNS ON ITSELF
WIELDING THE EXACT WEAPONS IT
WIELDS AGAINST EVERYONE ELSE AND
ACCUSES ITSELF OF RACISM.
IT IS PROSPEROUS BUT IT IS ALSO
A DIFFERENT MATTER.
I THINK WHAT WE ARE WITNESSING
IS THE MOST DANGEROUS IMPORT
FROM THE ACADEMY INTO THE REAL
WORLD.
STUDENTS ARE TAUGHT FROM THE
MOMENT THEY ARRIVE ON CAMPUS,
TWO THINGS IN TWO THINGS ONLY
RELIABLY, WHICH IS THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING ABOUT THEMSELVES
IS THEIR GROUP IDENTITY DEFINED
BY GONADS AND MELANIN, AND THAT
RACISM AND SEXISM BASED ON THOSE
CHARACTERISTICS ARE THE DEFINING
FEATURES OF AMERICAN SOCIETY.
TAUGHT TO BELIEVE THAT WHEN THEY
FACE ANY KIND OF DISAGREEMENT
THEY REFLEXIVELY ACCUSE THEIR
IDEOLOGICAL OPPONENTS OF BIGOTRY
AND HATE, AND THAT WORKS
WONDERFULLY ON A COLLEGE CAMPUS.
HE ACCUSED THE PRESIDENT OF
RACISM, HE IMMEDIATELY CRUMPLES
AND ORDERS ANOTHER MILLION
DOLLARS IN DIVERSITY
BUREAUCRACY.
YOU ACCUSE A CORPORATION OF
RACISM AND THE PREPOSTEROUS
CLAIM THAT THE BETSY ROSS FLAG
AS RACIST.
IT WORKS WITH POLITICIAN WITH
BIDEN REPUDIATING HIS JUSTIFIED
REPORT FOR THE APOSTATE UNITED
FOUR CRIME BILL THAT SAVED
THOUSANDS OF MINORITY LIVES.
THE QUESTION IS, THAT WORK FOR
THE REST OF US?
AND IF IT DOES, CIVIL SOCIETY IS
OVER BECAUSE THIS IS A
TOTALITARIAN POWER PLAY, AND
ATTEMPT TO SHUT DOWN ANY SORT OF
DIALECTICAL SEARCH FOR TRUTH AND
TO OCCUPY THE SOUL ALLOWABLE
IDEOLOGICAL GROUND.
AND THAT IS A RECIPE FOR A
SOCIETY TO HALT DEAD IN ITS
TRACKS AND GO IN REVERSE.
>> Tucker: BECAUSE IT IS NOT
REALLY AN ARGUMENT.
NOBODY IS MAKING A CASE.
BY THE WAY, THIS ELIMINATES THE
NEED TO MAKE THE CASE.
YOU DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE TO
CONVINCE ANYBODY OF ANYTHING IF
YOU ARE DOING IT TO FIGHT
RACISM, IT'S A MORAL IMPERATIVE
AND EVERYONE ELSE CAN SHUT UP
AND OBEY.
>> THERE HAS BEEN POLITICAL
DISAGREEMENTS LONG BEFORE
IDENTITY POLITICS.
PEOPLE DISAGREE, THAT IS WHAT
AMERICA IS ABOUT.
THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHT, WE HAVE
THE FREEDOM TO DEBATE OUR
OPINIONS.
THE ALTERNATIVE TO DEBATE IS
VIOLENCE.
IT IS AN ACT OF NARCISSISM TO
THINK THAT EVERYTHING IS ABOUT
YOURSELF, TO IMMEDIATELY SAY,
WELL IT MUST BE BECAUSE OF MY
GENDER AND RACE THAT I'M BEING
DISAGREED WITH AND YOU MUST BE A
BIGOT TO DISAGREE WITH ME.
NO, THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT DESERVE TO
BE FLESHED OUT IN THE PUBLIC
FORUM AND IF THEY ARE NOT, WE
ARE APPROACHING A TOTALITARIAN
STATE VERY QUICKLY.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A MUCH
LONGER CONVERSATION BUT IN A
SHORT TIME, WOULD YOU
RECOMMEND -- WHAT COURSE OF
ACTION FOR NORMAL PEOPLE?
IGNORE THESE SLURS FOR THE
CYNICAL POLITICS THAT THEY ARE?
HOW SHOULD THE AVERAGE PERSON
FIGHT BACK AGAINST THIS
TOTALITARIANISM?
SPEAK OF THE AVERAGE PERSON HAS
TO SIMPLY REJECT THE RACISM
CHARGE.
ALL OF US HAVE TO WORKING ON
ALTERNATIVE EXPLANATIONS FOR OUR
REALITY.
RACISM IS NO LONGER THE
PREDOMINANT CHARACTERISTIC OF
AMERICA, IF IT EVER WAS.
IT WAS A PART OF IT, IT WAS
NEVER THE DEFINING FEATURE.
BUT IT CERTAINLY IS NOT.
THIS STILL REMAINS THE LAND OF
OPPORTUNITY.
THE ALTERNATIVE EXPLANATION IS
THAT THERE ARE PROFOUND
BEHAVIORAL DIFFERENCES, CHOICES
THAT INDIVIDUALS MAKE THAT
DETERMINE SOCIAL OUTCOMES.
WE HAVE TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST